the edible myth is is a very complicated
thing in spite of what the freudians say
and one cannot really look at it uh
separately from the greek tradition that
when
a man has to overcome the mother demon
and that was the moment when oedipus had
to answer the riddle of the sphinx who
is
a maternal mother demon a devouring
mother figure
he did it by by giving a witty
intellectual answer
that is a way how certain men escape
the devouring mother they don't do not
slay the dragon
they they outwit the dragon so to speak
nowadays those are the men who
study theoretical physics and become
very intelligent
and knowing all the mathematics and
therefore
having a realm a masculine realm of
their own where their mother cannot
follow them
they build up a kind of mental masculine
world
such an escape into the intellectual or
scientific realm
has been for instance done by the
society around socrates and plato in
greece
that was an escape into the a pure
men's society of philosophers and
scientists among themselves
and we know that they were mostly
homosexual
or that socrates didn't get on with his
wife
santipe at all had a very unhappy
marriage
in other words the the the problem of
the feminine
and the getting away from the mother is
only seemingly achieved
there there must be another round in the
battle with the great mother
and that is what the edi pus myth
mirrors oedipus
thinks he has answered the riddle of the
swings and
happily goes off having outwitted her
and she
even in her evil witch-like behavior
pretends to commit suicide so to give
him that illusion
now i've overcome the mother with the
powers of the mind
and he just runs into marrying his own
mother
with all the tragedy and the divine
punishment
which befalls him on account of that
so this myth shows that
the masculine intellectual
overcoming of the devouring powers of
the unconscious is not enough
it has to be done by the way one lives
not by the way one thinks
just as it wouldn't help the young man
who has to take a room
to for himself to understand that he has
a mother complex and that all his
neurotic symptoms comes from his
mother thai he has to actually take the
other room and stand the battle
if he takes the other room does he have
to understand why he's doing it
yes certainly otherwise at the next
occasion when he runs out of money he
moves back to mama again
perhaps he finds a disagreeable landlady
in his first room so he
moves back home again he has to
understand
why he does it and that it is vitally
essential
for him that it is not just a technical
change in his life